[inaudible]
well it's,
it's stressful.
I suppose in some ways it'd be,
um,
these,
I don't find these,
these parks particularly stressful
because they're so positive.
You know,
I like to come up and talk about
the things that I've learned
a few people here and to have a serious
discussion about things that would help
orient us in the world and to
push what I know farther ahead.
So that's,
it's so positive that I don't
really think about this.
Certainly this part of it that stressful
facing journalists is stressful.
No,
usually
and so,
um,
I don't know how I have mine from that
or you should go sleep afterwards I guess
is what I do.
That helps.
That's helpful.
Um,
what I do to
increase my ability to tolerate
the activities that I'm engaged in,
this drama with my wife and she's
extremely helpful cause she's very level
headed.
I have an extra brain along which is a
useful thing and we sweat sometimes we
the workout with him.
Sometimes we go for a drive when we can
do that and we go for a walk and I spend
time with my family.
And,
um,
those are all good things,
but I go,
life is stressful.
So,
and at least I'm in a position where
whatever I'm doing new stressful is
counterbalanced by exactly what
that talk from all of you tonight.
I,
it's deep.
What I'm doing,
what I'm engaged in is deeply meaningful.
And so it's a pleasure to be able to
share that with other people and to see
that sense of meaningful
engagement and develop more people.
And it,
I can't think of anything
better to do than that,
which is why I'm doing
what I'm doing tonight,
for example,
because I can't think of anything better
than sitting here and talking to all of
you about these things that are necessary
to understand and to lay out in the
world.
And so
what do I do to unwind?
I think I do what you shouldn't
do if you want to unwind.
I,
I'm trying my best to make things better
because it seems to me that would be
better than this thing with feathers.
And I have some sense of how bad things
can be because I've studied how bad
things can be experienced
in my own personal life.
Some of them with my clients because
I've been in very dark places with my
clients and in my own
life from time to time,
certainly in my studies.
And I grabbed him that everything did
you go to hell in a hand basket like in
code?
And I would like it if everyone got on
the board and we all decided to make
things better.
Each of us started with our own
lives and facilitating that is
the afternoon to the catastrophe.
So that's a continual
unwinding in a sense.
So,
and it's a privilege to be able to take
part in m to also see this amazing thing
we developed in for a long time.
And now I started doing these lectures.
Public lectures would be last
year I did a series on the Bible.
I thought it was really at that because,
um,
well think about it is I decided
to do a series of lectures.
So I rented this theater and I
decided that I wanted to do lectures.
On Genesis sections of
what responsibilities,
starting with genesis.
And then I would do that publicly and
then a whole bunch of people came,
no one.
So that was pretty weird.
That young man's where exactly.
If not the people who
would ever to do that.
Lots of people have to 1,000,002 and
a half million people have watched the
first of those lectures.
It's on the first sentence of Genesis.
So to mount to an,
and people have watched for three
hour lecture on one sentence
from the first story in the Bible.
It's completely ridiculous.
When I went home,
launched the publicists in London,
rented and speaker so that I can
talk about it sold out right away.
So then they rented number one for the
next day and it's sold out right away
until they read one the next week.
And it's salt though too.
And then the same thing
happened in Amsterdam.
And then I thought,
well that's interesting.
So about 15 zero units,
50 theatrical performances
in Toronto and in Europe.
I can probably go wherever it wants the
world and we'll talk about what I want
to talk about,
how much people will come.
So I thought,
well,
I might as well try that.
That's
my wife and I have been in,
I think this is the 58
city in four months.
And so here you all are.
We're having a very serious
conversation is properly in the world.
And so that's not stressful,
man.
That's great.
So it compared,
there's so much worth catastrophe in
the world to be involved in a continual
conversation with thousands of people
about how each of our individual lives
might be better and how that
could spread into our families,
into the broader community.
It's like that's not stressful.
That's the opposite of stressful.
It's great.
Wonderful.
It's so positive.
I can't believe it.
You know,
I was talking to my son
the other day this morning,
I think,
and it was this morning
[inaudible] he gave,
he gave to the pay with tabby and I,
and we had a hell of a
trip man from New York,
from Dublin,
and then to London.
And so in Dublin I talked to
Sam Harris and Douglas Murray,
8,500 people showed up wearing this
big stadium was like the biggest
philosophical discussion.
I think it was the biggest
public philosophical discussion,
not like close it [inaudible] if it
was that would be the biggest event.
And that was like all these people
showed up cavernous Rena to him to hear a
very difficult discussion about the
relationship between facts and values and
religion and science.
They were like right into,
you know,
we were going to switch to Q and
a after an hour of discussion,
but the audience voted overwhelmingly,
you know,
by clapping too,
to continue the conversations.
And we talked for two and a half hours
and everyone was like right on the board.
And so it just turns out that people
are lot smarter than we thought.
There's a huge,
huge,
well I think TV,
the narrow bandwidth of
TV maybe made a mistake.
We were stupid and we're actually not.
And so there's this massive
public hungered for detail and,
and,
and reasonably deep
philosophical discussions like,
well that's helping with leasing things.
So that was just the one
belief [inaudible] we get that.
And I was crazily exciting,
ridiculously adventurous and the
talk went really well and will take,
hopefully,
like I said,
that the me in August and
that people can see what they,
and when there was a discussion about
the relative merits of an atheist
materialist viewpoint,
let's call it cultural
religious traditions,
religious viewpoint.
And we had a good discussion.
We consider yourself both
sides of that argument.
And then,
you know,
with any luck and a couple of billion
people will watch those videos and they
can have a discussion about it and they
do the concern himself up property.
And then we went to London and did the
same thing again along with a variety of
other activities.
Like I said,
I was talking to my son about this
morning and he's a pretty tough kid and
pretty levelheaded.
And when he was talking about it,
it made him broke down
at the rate of crime.
And you know,
and the reason for that is because it's
absolutely overwhelming to watch this
happen.
I can't believe.
So it's not stressful.
It's,
it's,
it's a privilege to be doing this.
It's an ounce,
lucky,
privileged to be doing this
and that sold [inaudible].